-And finally,
two weeks ago,
a series of
group-chat messages
sent by the governor
of Puerto Rico
and his advisers
leaked to the press.
It contained misogynist
and homophobic comments
in a conversation
where the group laughed
about victims of
Hurricane Maria.
After years of
political corruption,
it was the last straw,
so Puerto Ricans
took to the streets
to demand the governor's
resignation.
One of our writers,
Jenny Hagel,
is Puerto Rican,
and she's here to comment.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks, Seth.
Earlier this month,
Puerto Ricans obtained evidence
that their leader
was corrupt and immoral.
So, what did they do?
Wait two years
for Robert Mueller
to write the world's longest
book report?
No. They took matters
into their own hands.
They staged
a two-week-long protest
demanding that
the governor resign,
and they made the whole thing
look like a giant party.
Take a look.
♪♪
That's a political protest.
That looked for fun
than most weddings.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Plus, it's not every day
you get to see someone
fight injustice
with a cowbell.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone was out
in the streets --
young people, old people,
even Spiderman.
Or, as he's known in
Puerto Rico, Pedro Parker.
[ Laughter ]
Protesters played instruments
in the streets,
and people who didn't
have instruments
banged pots and pans.
Watch this woman stand up to
a group of police officers
in riot gear.
[ Laughter ]
We're over here
on the mainland going,
"The new is so overwhelming.
What can I do?"
And this woman's like,
"Do you have a pot?"
[ Laughter ]
"Bang it."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
These demonstrations brought out
the best in everyone.
10 years ago,
Ricky Martin was in the closet.
Last week, he was in the middle
of that protest,
on top of a truck,
waving this flag.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's like he's performing in
a way more fun revival
of "Les Mis."
[ Laughter ]
By the way,
it's not a coincidence
that Ricky Martin
was there.
In those leaked text messages,
a government official
made a homophobic joke
about him.
Imagine insulting a celebrity
on a text chain
with your friends, and then,
that celebrity comes for you
in real life.
That's terrifying.
That's like if you said you
didn't like the season finale
of "Big Little Lies,"
and then, suddenly,
Meryl Streep was
outside your window.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
But here's the thing about the
demonstrations in Puerto Rico --
They weren't just cool.
They worked.
After two weeks,
the governor resigned.
Puerto Ricans got their
corrupt leader out of office
in two weeks.
We've had
two and a half years,
and we can't get ours
off Twitter.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Donald Trump thinks
Puerto Ricans aren't Americans.
Well, last week, they were
the best example of Americans.
They exercised their rights to
free speech and free assembly,
and they peacefully protested
wrong until they made it right.
Plus, they avenged
Ricky Martin.
So, let's follow their example.
Call you representatives.
Volunteer. Canvass. Protest.
And if that seems like
too much, do you have a pot?
Bang it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jenny Hagel, everybody.